you intentionally gained a whole bunch
of weight yeah for uh the prior season
yes to season five season five and then
for this season six I
got shredded so when you when you gained
you gained a lot of weight I gained 40
I wasn't good at it it was like
fluctuating a lot you could see my
weight fluctuate throughout the like
throughout the episodes too and it was
it was probably 40 45 pounds it was fun
it was awesome it was that was the most
fun body modification that was like
pizza at night all the Pina Coladas you
could ingest peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches at night and then you get
really depressed but in the beginning
it's awesome
is I never had a
I I am older and I never had problems
with
wait ever I was always skinny and I
could always eat whatever I want but
after that season I ha like your fat
cells when they expand they
um they just go oh I can do that now and
now for the first time I have to like
watch what I eat and I can't drink as
much as I want and I I permanently uh
jack myself up but um and what do you uh
and then I got shredded for this season
and then as soon as I wrapped we wrapped
last year this shooting this season and
uh the second I wrapped I ate like an
entire unsliced pizza and then I went to
bed and then I woke back up and then I
ate like six bagels and then I went to
Portugal and I drank like 40 gallons of
wine and then it just all went you know
okay like all came crashing down we
still look good you look I mean this is
you know yeah yeah I when you came in I
thought like no he's looking good he's
looking good it's a lot more I'm wearing
a lot more sweatpants and a lot less
jeans that's a sign that a little thick
calling it thick to work but you should
I look like um
when I take my shirt off I look like uh
an orangutan about to breastfeed
so very maternal
that's great just voluptuous Brown a
male orangutan about to breastfeed which
is very rare those are the rarest of all
right you know what I can identify is I
think we were both the same this way is
I had this great run right a crazy high
metabolism yeah and I could not so in my
20s and 30s and I look at pictures of
myself from that era and I was eating
like a maniac disgusting egg I uh have a
very clear memory of getting lunch and
this is when I'm at SNL and Dana
carvey's there and he's watching me and
I order a cheeseburger and french fries
and I order a chocolate ice cream soda
with chocolate ice cream yeah and then
when that's done I order a Coke and I
drink the Coke and then when that's done
I order an ice cream sundae and he and
I'm skinny as a rail and he said how old
are you Conan and they said um 24 and he
went enjoy this for most of us learning
a second language in high school or
college wasn't exactly a high point in
our academic careers I uh learned
Spanish just many times over yeah it
didn't really stick no well you're very
Irish okay that doesn't have anything to
do and it's not like you went home to
anyone who spoke Spanish you just need
to practice it that's father my father's
from Spain oh I know he's a matador
anyway now thanks to Babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn
the new language babble's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go with Babel you
can choose from 14 different languages
including
Spanish French Italian German there are
so many ways to learn with Babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts games video stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee you know when I go
to another country I like to have some
facility with the language because it
shows that you're trying yeah it's like
a very uh courteous thing to do but it
could be tedious if it's like boring how
to learn it but this is fun I've tried
Babel and it is really fun they they do
teach you things that you'll use when
you go to another country and and it's
stuff that sticks right now get up to 55
off your subscription when you go to
babel.com Team Coco that's babel.com
teamcoco for up to 55 off your
subscription that's a big chunk off your
welcome World Babble language for life
and so now he's right I I flash back to
that and go oh yeah that's what he was
talking about the metabolism slows down
yeah it does that's why I do cocaine
it speeds things up it speeds it
up
and I smoke a lot it really helps kill
the appetite HGH
that'd be great I do I have fantasized
some about taking a lot of I want to
start doing crazy stuff steroids and and
getting jacked like Carrot Top yeah
Carrot Top I just saw him live oh yeah
for my 40th birthday I went to Vegas
with my friends yeah and I and before my
friends got there I just went and saw a
show it was incredible yeah I think he
gets people are too mean to him yeah
we're mean to him in the 90s yeah I
thoroughly enjoyed it and he was a total
sweetheart and he is
[Music]
he's a very nice guy he's a very sweet
guy but he's crazy jacked and I thought
my fans would just be think it was
really funny yeah I suddenly got jacked
yeah they would laugh at it yeah they
would and and also
um anything I tried to do after that
wouldn't be funny yeah yeah that's why I
like okay it all came crashing down like
I was in the best shape I'd been since I
was like 18 years old but I was like
this has no comedic value really and
it's only funny in relationship to the
previous season because it's such a
drastic change but uh as a as a as a
life choice like a comedian you can't be
you can't be ripped as a comedian right
also I mean like you have to be it's
very hard gross you have to look
disgusting it's very I get infuriated
when incredibly good looking people are
very funny duh it enrages me and I'm
thinking of like Jon Hamm is really
funny oh and uh Tim Oliphant is really
funny and their torture and it enrages
me because I think no no this was my
consolation yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
the cookie I got yeah because I was born
looking like this not yet you can't give
it to him he can't get the same cookie
that I got it's not it's not fair it's
like that Drew Carey joke
he's the funniest joke he said these
nude paparazzi photos of Brad Pitt
leaked where he was naked and he had a
huge penis and he's like that's not fair
he's like you can't be that good looking
and have a huge penis he's like Ron
Jeremy we get it okay
they gave him something as he was headed
out the door in just before they sent
him to Earth they're like oh we're sorry
give him one of these
elephant trunk there you go you feel
better now kind of
and you're carrying guns this guy's it's
on very so hot he said got such a big
and then JK goes I'm sitting at
home jerking off to a bootleg copy of
precious this guy's Angelina
Jolie
I know I'm giving him credit I know
Comics get sensitive about but it's an
ill joke that he's probably done a bunch
of times Drew Carey's gonna come after
me after this he's gonna come after you
now
any of those game shows in a day he
doesn't know how dirty have you seen his
stand-up live He's hella dirty oh really
yeah yeah cause he does the game shows
and you can't be dirty on the game shows
so it's nice it's Ben dub and he says
crazy
it's hardcore it's like a GG Allen
concert why doesn't he just do it one
time on the game show on the game show
like that and then just do one where he
goes for it and then of course they can
air it but they put it online and they
they give everyone a prize in the
audience so they're all happy why not
because we live in a weird puritanical
Society where we still have
standards and practices and sensor
boards and it's like an old tool it's an
old school thing censorship right you
can't say a curse word or it will put a
curse on your family that's a crazy
that's medieval right yeah it's less and
less I mean when I got into it there
really was I remember having uh you
couldn't say hell I meant I wrote a
sketch for Chris Rock and and
um I remember sitting down with actual
people in suits who were saying all
right let's go through this this word's
out really this words out yeah like the
senses yes yes you really met the
sensors oh they they came in and they
were like oh this is out and this is out
and of course this is out and
um but then what's was really weird is I
would offer Replacements that were often
worse and they would say yes of course
because they just wanted to show that
they had done right their job we went in
and we did our job and we took this
stuff out so we took out penis and then
Conan put in massive cockaroo